[Musica]
Allora il mio ruolo sarà un po' quello
di parlarvi di una notizia di cui si
parla molto poco che in questo periodo è
stata
nascosta perché non è stata
pubblicizzata molto sui giornali
Giustamente ci sono state notizie più
importanti si è parlato di pandemia si è
parlato di guerra Si è parlato
giustamente anche di ambiente poi ci
sono state molte notizie anche di
cronaca nera ma c'è una notizia
determinante cioè noi nel 2021 abbiamo
perso una città come Bari perché sono
morte oltre 300.000 persone per la
visione
309.635 non è che sono proprio morte
cioè il saldo tra i nuovi nati e i morti
e di meno 39 mila persone
una città come Bari pensate che l'anno
precedente complice anche il covid
abbiamo perso una città come Firenze
350 mila persone bisogna un po'
immaginarselo questo bisogna immaginarsi
l'Italia una cartina dell'Italia e a un
certo punto fu scompare una città con
tutti i suoi abitanti perché sono molti
di più i morti ogni anno in Italia
rispetto ai nuovi nati quest'anno
abbiamo raggiunto il record dei Record
399.000 nuovi bambini che diciamo sarà
battuto il prossimo anno perché i dati
sono usciti ieri quindi sono
particolarmente freschi saranno
385.000 nuovi nati rispetto ai 399.000
Pensate solo al livello così per avere
così una indicazione che nel 1945
seconda guerra mondiale i bambini che
nascevano erano circa 800 8 50.000 che
noi siamo in una situazione
spaventosa
Catone che è diciamo era ormai andato un
Senatore Romano amava ripetere una frase
che sicuramente tutti voi conoscete era
una frase che ripeteva come un mantra
Cartago delenda est cioè bisogna
distruggere Cartagine bisogna
uccidere quel nemico e lo faceva tirando
fuori da sotto la tunica un piatto di
fichi freschi perché fichi freschi
perché lui voleva fondamentalmente
mostrare che Cartagine era molto più
vicina di quanto ci si immaginasse cioè
voleva mostrare che era una minaccia che
addirittura faceva arrivare i fichi
freschi con le navi dell'epoca Anche noi
abbiamo la nostra Cartagine Anche noi
abbiamo un nemico contro cui combattere
ed è un nemico silenzioso è un nemico di
cui tante volte non ce ne rendiamo reso
conto che è proprio l'inverno
demografico ora Io vi sto facendo questo
pistolotto enorme perché perché parlando
con i demografi i demografi diciamo
tirano fuori i dati parlano con i numeri
mostrano le tendenze mostrano Dove
stiamo andando ma sempre ragionando con
i numeri
nelle chiacchierate che facciamo in
maniera informale loro mostrano e dicono
dove stiamo andando e fanno anche delle
valutazioni politiche e poi chiaramente
non possono essere riprese di loro studi
che devono attenersi ai numeri Allora
visto che loro non lo possono dire vi
dico io dove stiamo andando E cosa
succederà se non invertiamo questa
tendenza Allora prima di tutto crollerà
il PIL Il prodotto interno lordo Perché
Perché economia e Democrazia sono
strettamente collegate avete letto forse
sui giornali questi ultimi mesi che
diciamo ci sono più lavori rispetto a
giovani che vogliono lavorare ma non
perché i giovani non vogliono lavorare
anche se si è fatta molta polemica su
questo argomento Ma perché mancano
proprio i giovani Cioè si è scoperto che
ci sono più lavori rispetto al numero
dei giovani seconda cosa che accadrà è
che sta accadendo crollerà il Welfare
noi nel 2018 abbiamo speso grossomodo
493 miliardi di euro per il Welfare
quindi per aiutare le persone in
difficoltà le persone più fragili nel
2021 la cifra è diventata di 632
miliardi che cosa ci dice questa cifra
ci dice che diminuendo il numero dei
lavoratori ma Aumentando il numero delle
persone fragili quindi delle persone
anziane automaticamente aumenta la spesa
sociale Ma se il numero di lavoratori
diventa sempre più esiguo e automatico
che è difficile mantenere una spesa
sociale di questo tipo quindi crollerà
il peer i più fragili saranno sempre più
fragili diminuirà e crollerà il sistema
pensionistico perché se oggi grosso modo
c'è un lavoratore per un pensionato nel
prossimo futuro questo diventerà ancora
più insostenibile L'altro giorno mio
figlio Gabriele quello diciamo il
penultimo
stavamo sul motorino mi sentiva parlare
un'intervista Papa Ma che cosa sono le
pensioni
io l'ho guardato ho detto Ma che te
frega dico cioè dico guarda È inutile io
te lo posso pure spiegare Gabriele però
alla fine rosichi Scegliete lo spiego Ma
tu rosicherai perché è una cosa che tu
non avrai è qualcosa che tu ti metterai
in difficoltà quarto punto cosa molto
grave crollerà il sistema sanitario
nazionale
In che senso nel senso che sarà a
pagamento Perché se come stiamo dicendo
diminuisce il numero di chi paga le
tasse Il sistema sanitario nazionale si
basa su chi paga le tasse che permette
una gratuità a tutto il sistema Se
aumenteranno gli anziani se come le
previsioni dicono nel 2030 ci saranno 5
milioni di non autosufficienti in più
che cosa succederà facile che andremo io
andrò a giocare a calcetto a basket con
i figli o con chi volete voi prenderò la
classica storta e quando andrò in
ospedale dovrò strisciare la carta di
credito per farmi la lastra perché che
diventerà un servizio a pagamento
un'altra cosa che può capitare E che sta
capitando il mutuo delle case che stiamo
acquistando che Abbiamo acquistato che
stiamo pagando profondamente
personalmente con un mutuo trentennale
perderanno di valore Perché Perché nelle
città diminuirà la popolazione aumenterà
il numero degli immobili a disposizione
e quindi crollerà il valore delle case
per quanto riguarda le scuole è stato
detto l'avete letto anche sui giornali
non si parla più di classi pollaio
perché non nascono più pulcini e così
via Allora quello che vi sto dicendo non
è terrorismo psicologico
Purtroppo la pura realtà purtroppo è
quello che già sta accadendo sicuramente
Avete visto su Netflix il film Don't
took Club quello di con Di Caprio no
dove si parla di questo asteroide di
questa cometa che sta per venire e
diciamo impattare sulla terra questi
astronomi se ne accorgono lo raccontano
lo dicono in giro
in un certo senso si assume una certa
consapevolezza del problema ma è una
consapevolezza così
così le persone non sanno poi che fare
continuano le loro vite non hanno il
coraggio di guardare il problema di
alzare gli occhi al cielo e di capire
che c'è un problema che li sta per
travolgere si aspetta il miracolo per
l'appunto
è un po' quello che sta avvenendo qui
noi stiamo aspettando il miracolo Noi
stiamo aspettando che accada qualcosa
noi non ci rendiamo conto che il
terremoto già è arrivato e ha distrutto
O perlomeno a compromesso le fondamenta
della casa solamente che noi non vediamo
le crepe sul muro E allora pensiamo che
tanto in qualche modo si risolverà tanto
poi alla fine Una soluzione si trova ed
è lo stesso approccio che abbiamo con
l'ambiente con l'ambiente abbiamo lo
stesso approccio si sciolgono i
ghiacciai li unisce la possibilità di
mantenere di avere acqua potabile alcune
zone del mondo Abbiamo visto che cosa è
stata quest'estate La siccità
l'inquinamento dei mari Eppure facciamo
riunioni che che provocano ulteriori
riunioni che ehm Summit mondiali che poi
non portano a nulla perché perché
aspettiamo che i problemi diventino
emergenze ed è quello che sta capitando
il PNR
piano di resilienza abbiamo sentito
parlare ormai conosciamo più il PNR di
qualsiasi libro che abbiamo letto nella
nostra vita io l'ho letto tutto quindi
meriterei un applauso solo per questo
perché è un pistolotto di questo tipo
grazie non era
[Applauso]
nel PNR non c'è la parola natalità è
solamente accennata Ora io dico Noi
stiamo prendendo risorse non gratis
perché quelle si pagheranno le stiamo
prendendo dal futuro dei nostri figli
senza chiederglielo li stiamo prendendo
in prestito Ma poi le pagheranno loro e
non c'è in questo piano una visione che
tenga conto del tema della natalità che
tenga conto della sostenibilità
intergenerazionale è una sorta di Piano
Marshall Alcuni hanno fatto degli studi
comparativi hanno visto che sono più
risorse addirittura di quelle che sono
state messe nel nostro paese con il
piano Marshall e andiamo a fare tutta
una serie di ragionamenti senza Tenere
presente della nuova questione sociale
allora mi domando e vi domando A che
serve l'innovazione e mettere soldi
sull'innovazione Se non riusciamo più a
mettere in moto a far nascere
l'innovazione dell'Innovazione che è un
bambino che nasce
A che serve investire risorse sulla
digitalizzazione se non nascono più
nativi digitali A che serve
immaginare di costruire asili nido e
badate bene Io sono fissato coi servizi
per le famiglie Se però prima non
nascono bambini che cosa succederà un
asilo nido diventerà una sorta di
cattedrale nel deserto E potrei
continuare allora urge e qua ce lo
dobbiamo dire in maniera molto chiara
una presa di posizione seria
urge non la ricerca di un miracolo ma
urge una consapevolezza nuova urge il
fatto di prendere seriamente questo tema
urge il trovare una soluzione concreta
politiche familiari serie
Sul modello francese Sul modello tedesco
urge una via italiana all'integrazione
degli immigrati che non possono essere
coinvolti nel progetto Italia solamente
per pagare le pensioni a noi che non ce
li avremo urge il mettere all'interno
del PNR Finalmente un piano per la
natalità Perché non possiamo essere
considerati in tutta Europa come il
paese delle pensioni Allora questa cosa
si può fare non è perché lo dico io si
può fare perché la Germania la sta
facendo la Germania investendo
recentemente risorse sul tema della
natalità e considerandolo non un
problema non un costo
Ma appunto un investimento ha raggiunto
i livelli della natalità del 1997 se la
Germania lo può fare Lo possiamo fare
anche noi dove c'è un desiderio di
famiglia e di natalità molto maggiore
che in tutti gli altri paesi europei lo
dicono gli studi del professor Rosina
dove se chiedi a un giovane tra 19 e 25
anni che cosa vuoi dalla vita La
risposta è un lavoro una famiglia e dei
figli e quando gli chiedi Quanti figli
due o più figli l'80%. le donne italiane
a cui viene chiesto quanti figli
vogliono la la gran parte dice due o più
figli oggi ne facciamo solamente 1,17
Allora è chiaro che si può fare ed è
chiaro anche che serve però una presa di
coscienza reale Perché qua l'asteroide
sta arrivando è inutile che ci girano
intorno È inutile andare dietro a tutta
una serie di narrazioni folli Su questo
tema
un esempio i figli inquinano
Adesso mi è arrivato un messaggino che è
uscito un grande quotidiano che dice la
nascita del primo figlio riduce il
cervello degli uomini Allora Voi capite
giuro lo trovate non faccio nomi del
quotidiano ma mi è arrivato un secondo
fa Infatti mi hanno detto dillo l'ho
detto
è chiaro che questa narrazione è una
narrazione folle un figlio inquina Cioè
noi vogliamo dire che il problema è
l'uomo Il problema è un bambino che
nasce o il problema è l'individualismo o
il problema è la gestione sbagliata le
risorse o il problema è l'egoismo o il
problema è il consumismo Il problema non
è mai l'uomo l'uomo è un miracolo l'uomo
è la realtà più importante che abbiamo
Allora è chiaro che va fatto un salto di
qualità e non serve solo la politica Io
sono qui per dirvi che serve il mondo
delle banche il mondo delle associazioni
il mondo delle imprese il mondo dei
sindacati il mondo dello Sport il mondo
dello spettacolo serve una
consapevolezza di tutti noi perché è un
tema reale è un tema che tocca le vite
di ciascuno di noi
concludo
è chiaro che io non ho fatto cinque
figli
perché
mi aspettavo che mi pagassero la
pensione
e non ho fatto cinque figli perché in
Italia hai delle politiche familiari
tali che se fai cinque figli allora vivi
meglio No anzi vivaci in Italia la
seconda causa di povertà rinascita di un
figlio pensate La prima è la perdita del
lavoro di uno dei componenti della
famiglia la seconda causa di povertà
nasce ad un figlio e non ho fatto cinque
figli perché faccio parte di una setta
dove ti dicono fai figli i tuoi figli fa
figli no E non ho fatto nemmeno cinque
figli perché non c'ho il televisore lo
dico perché alla grande No dice mai che
c'è il televisore ce l'ho però lo dico
preferisco fa altro la peggio No nel
senso che
ho fatto cinque figli come ti ha fatto i
figli come chi si è aperto a questo
miracolo di fatto che è la vita perché
era bello
io mia moglie non li volevamo i figli
lei è figlia unica Io volevo fare altro
nella vita immaginavo mia vita
totalmente diversa se abbiamo fatto 5
figli perché è nato il primo gli abbiamo
detto no vabbè è troppo bello Vabbè
fighissimo Cioè dobbiamo farne un altro
e l'altro è nato dopo un anno e qualcosa
e poi via via un po' come le ciliegie
diciamo
la mia vita è più semplice No per me è
molto più complessa e molto più
difficile però infinitamente più bella
questo ve lo posso dire con grande
sincerità perché un figlio non lo si fa
per pagare le pensioni un figlio lo si
fa Perché senti il desiderio di lasciare
a qualcuno questa vita un figlio lo si
fa Perché vivere e vedere il mare da
solo È riduttivo un figlio lo si fa
Perché Perché non lo vuoi fregare perché
voglio fare un regalo un figlio lo si fa
per questo allora Voi capite che
è particolare che la soluzione di questo
problema
È una delle poche soluzioni
non faticose
perché qui non si tratta di faticare
Qui si tratta di scopare Grazie
[Applauso]